it's perhaps the greatest fraud in the
history of the Silicon Valley tech bomb
this Sunday on 60 minutes we are
investigating the failed biotech company
Thera knows Stanford University dropout
Elizabeth Holmes created the innovative
blood testing company her startup was
backed by a distinguished board filled
with friends of former Secretary of
State George P Shultz in two years the
company's value grew larger than uber or
Spotify at the time Holmes was named the
youngest self-made female billionaire in
the world but it all came crashing down
after Schultz's grandson Tyler an
employee at Thera knows helped blow the
whistle I had a personal relationship
with Elizabeth she was close to my
family
and I felt like she was deceiving my
family and the public and almost every
media outlet including us here at CBS
bought into the Thera know Smith she's
on the cover of magazines Inc calls her
the next Steve Jobs do you think the
board if Sarah knows believed she could
be also that kind of revolutionary
leader yeah definitely the board was
completely sold did your grandfather
George Schultz think that too definitely
yeah as her wealth and reputation soared
Elizabeth Holmes took on the trappings
of power she bragged bulletproof windows
were installed in her office and she
traveled with a full-time security
detail fairness employees told us they
were closely watched and required to
sign non-disclosure agreements all
reinforced they said by a threatening
team of lawyers and private
investigators that's why when Tyler
Schultz alerted authorities in the
spring of 2014 he used a fake name why
did you come up with an alias I knew how
seriously Thera knows protected their
trade secrets I knew they would not take
it well if they knew that I was talking
to regulators those regulators ended up
closing down fairness and that drew the
attention of the Securities and Exchange
Commission and the FBI George P Shultz
in his first public comments about the
theros debacle praised his grandson to
CBS News saying quote for his courage
and great moral
characters so we talked to a number of
insiders in the company and it's quite a
story of deception that lasted many
years were they for the insiders fuel
fooled as well I mean well the
interesting thing is many of them
thought it's a good idea the ability to
take a pinprick worth of blood and be
able to do these tests but it never
worked and there was a series and series
and series of deceptive actions that
were taken place and so many of them
became disillusioned tried to quit
we're threatened and that's all part of
the story house of cards I can't wait
yeah at Sunday on 60 minutes hear from
one employee who said there are no
snowing Lee sent patients tests results
that could be inaccurate that's Sunday
right here on CBS we of course will be
watching